last time we were here last release i
did i think was
uh all about algol 60 and its 60th
birthday
we left it in a situation i think where
algol 60
it was agreed by everybody had been
enormously influential it was a rallying
point for discussions and so on
there were aspects of it that some
people didn't like but it did set down a
kind of
benchmark of sorts but you could
legitimately then ask and say well
all right so where did high level
languages
go after algol 60 was there
on the algol 60 committee uh oh heck
where do we go from here moment oh yes
there was
some of you i think will know that an
influential
member on the alcohol system committee i
mean we've talked about
bacchus and now john becker's pizza now
bacchus now a notational they weren't
the only people who managed to win the
turing acm award
just for what they did on the algol 60
committee
another person who benefited huge and
rightly
was niklaus viet a lot of you will know
all about him already
he was on the alcohol 60 committee very
respected
computer scientist he's from eth
electro technician ruler is that in
zurich
and uh he and his big friend tony hall
famous british computer scientist
were bedded into the alcohol 60
committee but
niklaus took the view and it helped
enormously
that although algol 60
was what was democratically decided that
they could do
for alcohol 60. he nicklaus would
run as a sort of parallel project almost
his version of what he thought was a bit
more sensible
so for example last time i just
mentioned the horror of what can go
wrong with call by name
so nicholas was having none of that and
he came up with his own
as it were sensible version
of uh algol called algol w w for the
earth
and of course i must now tell the
obligatory nicholas veerth
joke i don't know if this is true but if
it isn't true it should be true
and it's a very gentle and well-meant
joke because he he
deserves a lot he's been a very
influential figure
so there we are in the late 60s anybody
on the alcohol 60 committee
is getting endless invitations to talk
about
progress in programme language design
and what really goes on behind the
scenes
at the ifip algol 60 committee
and niklaus was not beyond accepting
some of these
and so the story goes that he gets
invited to america
introduced you know her professor dr
nicholas vietnam
from eth in zurich and he stands up and
says i want to thank you all very much
for inviting me here it is a great honor
i should say that it puzzles me
here i am in the united states of
america when i'm back in
europe even the clothier brits try very
hard with my name
they really try hard to say nicklaus
viet
and they get it pretty well right but
over here unfortunately
forever being called nicholsworth
and goes out from the audience and said
that's because europeans call you by
name
but americans call you by value and of
course i hope there's just collapses you
know
absolutely in joke of all in jokes but
the algol 60 committee
did a grand job but in the introspection
of having released it and it's been
pretty successful
so where do we go from here and i think
the next stage was code named algol
x a little subcommittee gets appointed
with un perhaps led i think by
nicholasville
i'm not sure and of course the
subcommittee came back and said the
obvious
route for alcohol x is just to do
alcohol w
which is what it should have been all
along but there was a
minority view which oh i don't know
felt very strongly about it led i think
by the free
university of amsterdam they had an
again a very
venerable and respected computer
scientist
called adrian van winegarden and he
and his followers strongly believed
that our goal x should take
a giant leap forward and not just be
concerned with
tidying up the loose ends on what went
wrong with our goal 60.
and such was the level of full and frank
exchange of opinions
i think tony horror and levitt and one
or two others
resigned in protest from work in group
2.1 which was the committee
that defined alcohol 60.
so that left behind a sort of rump of
equal fanatics but in a different
direction very interesting direction
and they eventually progressed to what
became known as algol 68
the algol w types sort of went off and
did their own thing and this
the the the result was a big success
it's called pascal we all know about
pascal
you can it it had a heavy take-up i
think because
compilers were available good computer
scientists could take a look at it and
say yeah i think i could implement that
it was a distillation if you like of
all the bits you could safely include
and one of pascal's strengths
but according to some also its
weaknesses
was that it deliberately restricted you
and kept
things simple so that it was suitable as
a teaching language
and it was very successful in that
regard no end of
people in computing companies and
universities thought oh i could write a
pascal compiler
it's not too bad and it did make some
important steps forwards for example
that you can do records in pascal you
can do pointers
but here's the start of trouble ahead
basically believed and he's right and it
was echoed years later by james gosling
pointers are dangerous pointers are some
of the most
dangerous things you can have in the
program well how do you cope with that
danger
and the answer from nicolas fiat in
pascal is you may have a pointer to
something
but only at that one level you can't you
can have appointed to an integer
but you cannot have a pointer to a
pointer to an integer
that fans immediately prevents it from
doing
the triple ref trick because we talked
about this a while ago you can do very
clever things
in list processing if only you can
handle pointers to pointers
to pointers even you just can't do that
in pascal
and in the correspondence that came
along with that episode i don't know
oh but my library can fill in for you
and if only you use extended pascal
which wasn't agreed until about 10 years
later
it works absolutely yes but at the time
there were limits what it could do with
pointers the idea was this is a language
for beginners and if you run out of
steam
um it's not too bad because
they'll go on to use more powerful
languages later on
which in a way was fair enough and there
were dozens of compilers created between
i think it was announced in 1969 pascal
and over the next decade lots and lots
and lots of compilers some of you will
know that
it even got onto microsoft and things
like
ucsd pascal yeah university of
california
at san diego so at the end of the 70s
a certain brian kernighan who was well
known to us
of course and is well known to us had
been working long hard
in the uh units committee at bell labs
to convert what is called of course in
unix parlance software tools it's the
bits and bobs that come with unix which
are so
valuable you know the sort functions the
grep the the bits and pieces that aren't
literally in the
kernel of the operating system but it
wouldn't be unix if you didn't have all
of these things going
and of course a lot of people said well
it's all right for you you do it in this
c
and all that we haven't got a c compiler
we like these tools
can you do them in other languages i
think it went like that
and brian's uh colleague bill plogger
originally i think
maybe both of them did a thing called
software tools in fortran
because that was still a big big deal in
those early days
and then once that had been established
they actually got down and said
right pascal very popular let's do
software tools in pascal
when that task was complete at the end
of the 70s early 80s
brian wrote a memo
which i'm glad to see is much less
contentious
than the infamous vacation memo about
jailbreaking typesetters but it caused a
lot of discussion
and at the end of that paper he comes up
with
nine things that pascal got wrong
or ignored it reminds those of us who
remember hitchhiker's guide to the
galaxy
there is a philosopher in that series
who allegedly
wrote this tone called where god went
wrong well all computer science can
offer is brian's list of nine places
where pascal went wrong
and although the pascal fans got
very huffy about it they had to admit
he'd got a point he knew what he was
talking about
he wasn't just talking about teaching
this language to a few kids
where you could leave out the bits you
didn't like and didn't understand
he'd actually done a considerable volume
of work
one or two of the things we could just
pick out here that he
pointed out was there is no way to
declare
a byte in a in
your pascal computer you can't declare
it as being a mode
bit at all you can't get down to the bit
level manipulation
he said all i wanted to do was to
exclusive or one bit pattern with
another which you do all the time in
cryptography
but i couldn't get down to the bit level
just couldn't
and then somebody says oh but there's a
library that will do it for you and it's
an assembler but that's not the point
the language itself won't let you do
that and so
people fond of the language first of all
when huffy about it but then i have to
say well
you've got a ghost of a point there i
must admit and from then on it's always
amused me that it became almost like a
thing you know
my argument here does this this and this
and it disposes of
kernighan's cases two seven and nine you
see
so it became very famous in that regard
he basically was pointing out
there are the pointers are
brain dead will only do level one it's
not a real system implementation
language because it can't do bits
it's um has no facilities for separate
compilation
you can't do bits and pieces of program
separately and link them together
afterwards he said
essentially this is fine it is a
teaching language
it does what it does well and it gives
you a
protected environment which you cannot
break out
of once you run out of steam with it
there are
no workarounds none
okay so you have to move on to something
else
60 did do was give at the syntactic
level and also at the
implementation facilities level enough
ken thompson faced with the problems of
fonts on the 202
where individual characters shouldn't
get too complex
you'll never guess how he did something
like